can you kind of give your wise Sage
advice about what humans who have never
interacted with the eye systems
uh not even like with wolf from Alpha
are now interacting with Chad GPT
because it becomes
it's accessible to a certain demographic
they may have not touched AI systems
before what do we do with truth like
journalists for example
yeah how do we think about the output of
these systems I think this idea
the idea that you're going to get
factual output is not a very good idea I
mean it's just this is not it is a
linguistic interface it is producing
language and language can be truthful or
not truthful and that's a different
slice of what's going on I think that
you know what we see
and for example uh kind of you know go
check this with your fact source for
example you can do that to some extent
but then it's going to not check
something it's going you know that is
again a thing that is sort of a does it
check in the right place I mean we see
that in you know does it call the you
know the Wolfman plug-in in the right
place you know often it does sometimes
it doesn't you know I I think the the
real thing to understand about what's
happening is which I think is very
exciting is kind of the the great
democratization of access to computation
yeah and and um you know I think that
when you look at sort of the there's
been a long period of time when
computation and the ability to figure
out things with computers has been
something that kind of only the only The
Druids at some level can can achieve you
know I myself have been involved in
trying to sort of de-druidify
um access to computation I mean back
before Mathematica existed you know in
1988 if you were a you know a physicist
or something like that and you wanted to
do a computation you would find a
programmer you would go and you know
delegate the the computation to that
programmer hopefully they'd come back
with something useful maybe they
wouldn't there'd be this long you know
multi-week you know Loop that you go
through and then it was actually very
very interesting to see 1988 you know
like first people like physicists
mathematicians and so on then other lots
of other people but this very rapid
transition of people realizing they
themselves could actually type with
their own fingers and you know make some
piece of code that would do a
computation that they cared about and
you know it's been exciting to see lots
of discoveries and so on made by by
using that tool and I think the same
thing is you know we see the same thing
you know Wolfman Alpha is dealing with
uh is not as deep computation as you can
achieve with whole woven language
Mathematica stack but the thing that's
to me particularly exciting about kind
of the large language model linguistic
interface mechanism is it dramatically
broadens the access to kind of deep
computation I mean it's kind of like one
of the things I've sort of thought about
recently is you know what's going to
happen to all these programmers what's
going to happen to all these people who
you know a lot of what they do is write
slabs of boilerplate code and in a sense
you know I've been saying for 40 years
that's not a very good idea you know you
can automate a lot of that stuff with a
high enough level language that slab of
code that's designed in the right way
you know that slab of code turns into
this one function we just implements it
you can just use
um so in a sense that the fact that
there's there's all of this activity of
doing sort of lower level programming is
something for me it seemed like I don't
think this is the right thing to do but
you know and and lots of people have
used our technology and not had to do
that but the fact is that that's you
know so when you look at I don't know
computer science departments that have
that have turned into places where
people are learning the trade of
programming so to speak it's it's sort
of a question of what's going to happen
and I think there are two Dynamics one
is that kind of uh sort of uh
boilerplate programming is going to
become you know it's going to go the way
that Assembly Language went back in the
day of something where it's really
mostly specified by at a higher level
you know you start with natural language
you turn it into a computational
language that's you look at the
computational language you run tests you
understand that's what's supposed to
happen you know if we do a great job
with compilation of the of the the you
know of the computational language it
might turn into llvm or something like
this but um uh you know or just directly
gets gets run through the algorithms we
have and so on but
but then so that's kind of a a tearing
down of this kind of this big structure
that's been built of of teaching people
programming but on the other hand the
other Dynamic is vastly more people are
going to care about computation so all
those Departments of you know art
history or something that really didn't
use computation before now have the
possibility of accessing it by virtue of
this kind of linguistic interface
mechanism and uh if you create an
interface that allows you to interpret
the debug and interact with the
computational language
then that makes it even more accessible
yeah well I mean the I think the thing
is that right now you know the average
you know art history student or
something probably isn't going to you
know they're not probably they don't
think they know about programming and
things like this but by the time it
really becomes a kind of purely you know
you just walk up to it there's no
documentation you start just typing you
know compare these pictures with these
pictures and you know see the use of
this color whatever and you generate
this piece of of computational language
code that gets run you see the results
you say oh that looks roughly right or
you say that's crazy
um and maybe then you eventually get to
say well I better actually try and
understand what this computational
language code did
um and and that becomes the thing that
you learn just like it's kind of an
interesting thing because unlike with
mathematics where you kind of have to
learn it before you can use it this is a
case where you can use it before you
have to learn it well I got a sad
possibility here or maybe exciting
possibility that very quickly people
won't even look at the computational
language they'll trust that it's
generated correctly as you get better
and better generating that language uh
yes I think that there will be enough
cases where people see you know because
you can make it generate tests too and
and so you'll say
um we're doing that I mean that's it's a
pretty cool thing actually yes but you
you know say this is the code and you
know here are a bunch of examples of
running the code yeah okay people will
at least look at those and they'll say
that example is wrong and you know then
it'll kind of wind back from there and I
agree that that the the kind of the
intermediate level of people reading the
computational language code in some case
people will do that in other case people
just look at the tests
and or even just look at the results and
sometimes it'll be obvious that you got
the thing you wanted to get because you
were just describing you know make me
this interface that has two sliders here
and you can see it has that those two
sliders there and that's that's kind of
that's that's the result you want but I
I think you know one of the questions
then is in that setting where you know
you have this kind of ability broad
ability of people to access computation
what should people learn you know in
other words right now you you know you
go to Computer Science school so to
speak and a large part of what people
end up learning I mean it's been a funny
historical development because back you
know 30 40 years ago computer science
departments were quite small and they
taught you know things like final
automata Theory and compiler Theory and
things like this
um you know company like mine rarely
hired people who'd come out of those
programs because the stuff they knew was
I think it's very interesting I love
that theoretical stuff but um you know
it wasn't that useful for the things we
actually had to build build in software
engineering and then kind of there was
this big pivot in the in the 90s I guess
where there was a big demand for sort of
I.T type programming and so on and
software engineering and then you know
big demand from students and so on you
know we want to learn this stuff and uh
and and I think you know the thing that
really was happening in part was lots of
different fields of human endeavor were
becoming computational you know for all
acts there was a there was a
computational x and this is a um uh and
that was the thing that um that people
were responding to
um and but then kind of this idea
emerged that to get to that point the
main thing you had to do was to learn
this kind of trade or or skill of doing
you know programming language type
programming and and that uh you know it
kind of is a strange thing actually
because I you know I remember back when
I used to be in the professor in
business which is now 35 years ago so
gosh that's rather long time
yeah
um you know it was it was right when
they were just starting to emerge kind
of computer science departments that
sort of a fancy research universities
and so on I mean some had already had it
but the the other ones that that um were
just starting to have that and it was
kind of a a thing where they were kind
of wondering are we going to put this
thing that is essentially a a trade-like
skill are we going to somehow attach
this to the rest of what we're doing and
a lot of these kind of knowledge work
type activities have always seemed like
things where that's where the humans
have to go to school and learn all this
stuff and that's never going to be
automated yeah and you know this is It's
kind of shocking that rather quickly you
know a lot of that stuff is clearly
automatable and I think you know but the
question then is okay so if it isn't
worth learning kind of uh you know how
to do car mechanics you only need to
know how to drive the car so to speak
what do you need to learn and you know
in other words if you don't need to know
the mechanics of how to tell the
computer in detail you know make this
Loop you know set this variable but you
know set up this array whatever else if
you don't have to learn that stuff you
don't have to learn the kind of under
the hood things what do you have to
learn I think the answer is you need to
have an idea where you want to drive the
car in other words you need to have some
notion of you know your you know you
need to have some picture of sort of
what the what the architecture of what
is computationally possible is well
there's also this kind of artistic
element of um of conversation because
you ultimately you use natural language
to control the car
so it's not just the where you want to
go well yeah you know it's interesting
it's a question of who's going to be a
great prompt engineer yeah okay so my
current theory this week good expository
writers are good prompt Engineers what's
an expository range so like uh somebody
who can explain stuff well huh police
department does that come from in the
University yeah I have no idea I think
they killed off all the expository
writing departments well there you go
strong words with Stephen Wolfram well I
don't know I don't I'm not sure if
that's right I mean I I actually am
curious because in fact I just sort of
initiated this kind of study of of
what's happened to different fields at
universities because like you know there
used to be geography departments at all
universities and then they disappeared
actually right before GIS became common
I think they disappeared you know
Linguistics departments came and went in
many universities it's kind of
interesting because these things that
people have thought were worth learning
at one time and then they kind of die
off and then you know I do think that
it's kind of interesting that for me
writing prompts for example well I
realize you know I think I'm an okay
expository writer and I realize when I'm
sloppy writing a prompt and I don't
really think because I'm thinking that
I'm just talking to an AI I don't need
to you know try and be clear in
explaining things that's when it gets
totally confused and I mean in some
sense you have been writing prompts for
a long time with wolf from alpha
thinking about this kind of stuff yeah
how do you convert natural language into
competition well right but that's a you
know the one thing that I'm wondering
about is uh you know it is remarkable
the extent to which you can address an
llm like you can address a human so to
speak and and I think that is because it
you know it learned from all of us
humans it's it's uh the reason that it
responds to the ways that we will
explain things to humans is because it
is a representation of how humans talk
about things but it is bizarre to me
some of the things that kind of are sort
of expository mechanisms that I've
learned in trying to write clear you
know expositions in English that you
know just for humans that those same
mechanisms seem to also be useful for
for for the llm but on top of that
what's useful is the kind of mechanisms
that maybe a psychotherapist employs
which is a kind of uh like almost
manipulative or game theoretic
interaction where Maybe
you would do with a friend like a
thought experiment that if this was the
last day you were to live or yeah if if
I ask you this question and you answer
wrong I will kill you those kinds of
problems seem to also help yes in
interesting ways yeah so it makes you
wonder like the way a therapist I think
would like a good therapist probably you
we create layers
in our human mind to between like uh
between between the outside world and
we'll just true what is true to us and
um maybe about trauma and all those
kinds of things so projecting that into
an llm maybe there might be a deep truth
that's it's concealing from you it's not
aware of it you get to that truth you
have to kind of really kind of
manipulate this yeah yeah right it's
like these jailbreaking jailbreaking for
llms and but the space of jailbreaking
techniques
as opposed to being fun little hacks
that could be an entire system sure yeah
I mean just think about the computer
security aspects of of how you you know
phishing and and computer security you
know fishing of humans yeah and fishing
of llms is is a is a they're very
similar kinds of things but I think I
mean this this um
uh you know this whole thing about kind
of the AI Wranglers AI psychologists all
that stuff will come the thing that I'm
curious about is right now the things
that are sort of prompt hacks are quite
human they're quite sort of
psychological human kinds of hacks the
thing I do wonder about is if we
understood more about kind of uh the
science of the llm will there be some
totally bizarre hack that is you know
like repeater word three times and put a
this that and the other there that
somehow plugs into some aspect of how
the llm works
um that is not you know that that's kind
of like like an optical illusion for
humans for example like one of these
mind hacks for humans what are the Mind
hacks for the llms I don't think we know
that yet and that becomes a kind of
us figuring out reverse engineering the
language that controls the llms and the
thing is the reverse engineering can be
done by a very large percentage of the
population now because it's natural
language interface right it's kind of
interesting to see that you were there
at the birth of the computer science
department
as a thing and you might be there at the
death of the computer science department
is the thing well yeah I don't know
there were computer science departments
that existed earlier but the ones the
the broadening of of every University
had to have a computer science
department yes I was I was uh I watched
that so to speak and but I think the
thing to understand is okay so first of
all there's a whole theoretical area of
computer science that I think is great
and you know that's a fine thing the the
you know in a sense you know people
often say any field that has the word
science tacked onto it probably isn't
one yeah um and strong words right and
that's the uh nutrition science
Neuroscience that one's an interesting
one because that one is also very much
you know there's a that's a chat GPT
informed science in a sense because it's
it's kind of like the the big problem of
Neuroscience has always been we
understand how the individual neurons
work we know something about the
psychology of how overall thinking works
yeah what's the kind of Intermediate
Language of the brain and nobody has
known that and that's been in a sense if
you ask what is the core problem of
Neuroscience I think that is the core
problem that is what is the level of
description of brains that's above
individual neuron firings and Below
psychology so to speak and I think what
chat GPT is showing us is well one one
thing about Neuroscience is you know one
could have imagined There's Something
Magic in the brain there's some weird
quantum mechanical phenomenon that we
don't understand one of the important
you know discoveries from chatgpt is
it's pretty clear you know brains can be
represented pretty well by simple
artificial neural net type models and
that means that's it that's what we have
to study now we have to understand the
science of those things we don't have to
go searching for you know exactly how
did that molecular biology thing happen
inside the synapses and you know all
these kinds of things we've we've got
the right level of modeling to be able
to explain a lot of what's going on and
thinking we don't necessarily have a
science of what's going on there that's
the that's the remaining challenge so to
speak but we you know we know we don't
have to dive down to some some different
layer but anyway we were talking about
things that had science in their name
yes and um you know I think that the uh
um
you know what what happens to computer
science well I think the thing that um
uh you know there is a thing that
everybody should know and that's how to
think about the world computationally
and that means you know you look at all
the different kinds of things we deal
with and there are ways to kind of have
a formal representation of those things
you know it's like well what is a what
is an image you know what how do we
represent that what is color how do we
represent that what is you know what are
all these different kinds of things what
is I don't know smell or something how
should we represent that what are the
shapes molecules and things that
correspond to that what is uh you know
these things about how do we represent
the world in some kind of formal level
and I think my my current thinking and
I'm not real happy with this yet but um
you know it's kind of computer science
it's kind of Cs and what really is
important is kind of computational X for
all X and there's this kind of thing
which is kind of like CX not Cs and CX
is a this kind of computational
understanding of the world that isn't
the sort of details of programming and
programming languages and the details of
how particular computers are made it's
this kind of way of formalizing the
world it's kind of kind of a little bit
like what logic was going for back in
the day and we're now trying to find a
formalization of everything in the world
you can kind of see you know we made a
poster years ago of kind of the uh the
the growth of systematic data in the
world so all these different kinds of
things that you know there were sort of
systematic descriptions found for those
things like you know what point do
people have the idea of having calendars
dates you know a systematic description
of what day it was at what point did
people have the idea you know systematic
descriptions of these kinds of things
and as soon as one can you know people
you know as a way of sort of formulating
how do you how do you think about the
world in a sort of uh a formal way so
that you can kind of build up a tower of
of cable abilities you kind of have to
know sort of how to think about the
world computationally it kind of needs a
name and it isn't you know we implement
it with computers so that's we talk
about it as computational but really
what it is is a formal way of talking
about the world what is the formalism of
the world so to speak and how do we
learn about kind of how to think about
different aspects of the world in a
formal way so I think sometimes when you
use the word formal
it uh kind of implies highly constrained
and perhaps that's not doesn't have to
be highly constrained so computational
thinking does not mean like logic it
knows it's a really really broad thing I
wonder I mean
I wonder if it's if you think natural
language will evolve such that
everybody's doing computational thinking
oh yes well so one question is whether
there will be a pigeon of computational
language and natural language yeah and I
found myself sometimes you know talking
to chat GPT trying to get it to write
wolf language code and I write it in
Pigeon form so that means I'm combining
you know uh you know Nest list this
collection of you know whatever you know
Nest list is a term from open language
and I'm combining that and chat does a
decent job of understanding that pigeon
probably would understand the pigeon
between English and French as well of
you know as a smooshing together of
those languages but yes I think that's
you know that's far from impossible and
what's the incentive for young people
that are like eight years old nine ten
they're starting to interact with Chad
GPT to learn the normal natural language
right the the full poetic language
what's the why the same way we learn
emojis and shorthand when you're texting
yeah they'll learn like language will
have a strong incentive to evolve into
uh maximally uh computational kind of
like perhaps you know I had this
experience a number of years ago I
happened to uh be visiting a person I
know on the on the west coast who's
worked with a bunch of kids aged I don't
know 10 11 years old or something who'd
learned woven language really well and
these kids learned it so well they were
speaking it and so show up in that like
saying oh you know this thing and
they're speaking this language I never
heard it as a spoken language they were
very disappointed that I couldn't
understand it at the speed that they
were speaking at it's like kind of I'm
it's um uh and so I think that's some I
mean I've actually thought quite a bit
about how to turn computational language
into a convenient spoken language I
haven't quite figured that out oh spoken
because it's readable right yeah it's
readable as a you know as a way that we
would read text but if you actually want
to speak it and it's useful you know if
you're trying to talk to somebody about
writing a piece of code it's useful to
be able to say something and it should
be possible and I think it's very
frustrating it's one of those problems I
maybe I maybe this is one of these
things where I should try and get an llm
to help me how to make it speakable
maybe maybe it's easier than you realize
when you want I think it is easier I
think it's one idea or so I think it's I
think it's going to be something where
you know the fact is it's a tree
structured language just like human
language is a true structured language
and I think it's going to be one of
these things where one of the
requirements that I've had is that
whatever the spoken version is that
dictation should be easy that is that
shouldn't be the case that you have to
relearn how the whole thing works it
should be the case that you know that
open bracket is just a uh ah or
something and it's you know and then
um but you know human language has a lot
of tricks that are I mean for example
human language
has has features that are sort of
optimized keep things within the bounds
that our brains can easily deal with
like I you know I tried to teach a
Transformer neural net to do parenthesis
matching it's pretty crummy at that it
it um and then chat gbt is similarly
quite crummy at parenthesis matching you
can do it for small parenthesis things
for the same size of parenthesis things
where if I look at it as a human I can
immediately say these are match these
are not matched but as soon as it gets
big as soon as it gets kind of to the
point where sort of a deeper computation
is hopeless and but the fact is that
human language has avoided for example
the Deep subclauses you know we don't um
uh you know we we arrange things so we
don't end up with these incredibly deep
things
um because brains are not well set up to
deal with that and we it's found lots of
tricks and maybe that's what we have to
do to make sort of a spoken version a a
a human speakable version because
because what we can do visually is a
little different what we can do in the
very sequentialized way that we that we
hear things in in the audio domain
let me just ask about MIT briefly so
there's now there's a College of
Engineering and there's a new College of
computing it's just interesting I want
to linger on this computer science
department thing so MIT has ex
electrical engineering computer science
um what do you think college of
computing will be doing like in 20 years
what what like well you see what happens
to computer science like really this is
the question this is you know everybody
should learn kind of whatever CX really
is okay the this how to think about the
world computationally everybody should
learn those Concepts and uh you know
it's uh and and some people will learn
them at a quite quite formal level and
they'll learn computational language and
things like that other people will just
learn you know uh sound is represented
as you know Digital Data and they'll get
some idea of spectrograms and
frequencies and things like this and
maybe that doesn't or they'll learn
things like you know a lot of things
that are sort of data science
statistics-ish like if you say oh I've
got these you know these people who who
um uh picked their favorite kind of
candy or something and I've got um you
know what's the best kind of candy given
that I've done the sample of all these
people and they all rank the candies in
different ways you know how do you think
about that that's sort of a
computational x kind of thing you might
say oh it's I don't know what that is is
it statistics is it data science I don't
really know but kind of how to think
about a question like that or like a
ranking of preferences yeah yeah and
then how to aggregate those those ranked
preferences into an overall thing you
know how does that work
um you know how how should you think
about that you know because you can just
tell you might just tell chat gbt sort
of I don't know even even the concept of
an average it's not obvious that you
know that's a concept that people it's
worth people knowing that's a rather
straightforward concept people people
you know have learned in kind of mathy
ways right now but there there are lots
of things like that about how do you
kind of have these ways to sort of
organize and formalize the world and
that's and these things sometimes they
live in math sometimes they live in in I
don't know what they you know I don't
know what you know learning about color
space I have no idea what I mean you
know there's obviously a field of
there's uh it could be vision science or
no color space you know color space
that's that would be Optics so like no
really it's not Optics Optics is about
you know lenses and chromatic aberration
of lenses and things like that so color
space is more like design and art is
that no I mean it's like you know RGB
space XYZ space you know Hue saturation
brightness space all these kinds of
things these are different ways to
describe colors right but doesn't the
application Define what that like
because obviously artists and designers
use the colors to explore sure no I mean
it's just an example of kind of how do
you you know the typical person how do
you how do you describe what a color is
or there are these numbers that describe
what a color is well it's worth you know
if you're an eight-year-old you won't
necessarily know you know it's not
something we're born with to know that
you know colors can be described by
three numbers
um that's something that you have to you
know it's a thing to learn about the
world so to speak
um and I think that you know that whole
Corpus of things that are learning about
the formalization of the world or the
computationalization of the world that's
something that should be part of kind of
standard education and you know there
isn't a you know there isn't a course
the curriculum for that and by the way
whatever might have been in it just got
changed because of llms and so on
significantly and yeah I would some
watching closely with interest seeing
how universities adapt well you know so
so one of my projects for hopefully this
year I don't know is to try and write
sort of a a reasonable textbook so to
speak of whatever this thing CX whatever
it is you know what should you know you
know what should you know about like
what a bug is what is the intuition
about bugs what's intuition about you
know software testing what is it what is
it you know these are things which are
you know they're not I mean those are
things which have gotten taught in in
computer science as part of the trade of
programming but but kind of the the
conceptual points about what these
things are you know it surprised me just
at a very practical level you know I
wrote this little explainer thing about
Chachi PT and I thought well you know
I'm writing this partly because I wanted
to make sure I understood it myself and
and so on and it's been you know it's
been really popular and um uh
surprisingly so and I then I realized
well actually you know I was sort of
assuming I didn't really think about it
actually I just thought this is
something I can write and I realized
actually it's a level of description
that is kind of you know what has to be
it's not the engineering level
description it's not the kind of just
the qualitative kind of description it's
some kind of sort of expository
mechanistic description of what's going
on together with kind of the bigger
picture of the philosophy of things and
so on and I realized actually this is a
pretty good thing for me to write I you
know I kind of know those things and I
kind of realized it's not a collection
of things that you know it's it's I've
sort of been I was sort of a little
shocked that it's as much of an outlier
in terms of explaining what's going on
as it's turned out to be and that makes
me feel more of an obligation to kind of
write the kind of uh you know what is
you know what is this thing that you
should learn about about the
computationalization the formalization
of the world
um because well I've spent much of my
life working on the kind of tooling and
mechanics of that and the science you
get from it so I guess this is my my
kind of obligation to try to do this but
I think so if you ask what's going to
happen to like the computer science
departments and so on there's there's
some interesting models so for example
let's take math you know math is the
thing that's important for for all sorts
of fields you know engineering you know
even you know chemistry psychology
whatever else and I think different
universities have kind of evolved that
differently I mean some say all the math
is taught in the math department
um and some say well we're going to have
a you know a math for chemists or
something that is taught in the
chemistry Department
um and you know I think that this this
question of whether there is a
centralization of the teaching of sort
of CX is an interesting question and I
think you know the way it evolved with
math
you know people understood that math was
sort of a separately teachable thing and
um I was kind of a you know a a an
independent element as opposed to just
being absorbed into now so if you take
the example of of writing English or
something like this
the first point is that that you know at
the college level at least fancy
colleges there's a certain amount of
English writing that that people do but
mostly it's kind of assumed that they
pretty much know how to write you know
that's something they learned at a an
earlier stage in education maybe rightly
or wrongly believing that but that's
different issue
um the uh uh well I think it it reminds
me of my kind of as I've tried to help
people do technical writing and things
I'm I'm always reminded of my zeroth law
of technical writing which is if you
don't understand what you're writing
about your readers do not stand a chance
yeah and so it's it's um uh I think the
um
the thing that uh has some uh you know
in when it comes to like writing for
example
um you know people in different fields
are expected to write English essays and
they're not you know mostly the you know
the history department or the
engineering department they don't have
their own you know let's you know it's
it's not like there's a I mean it's a
thing which sort of people are assumed
to have a knowledge of how to write that
they can use in all these different
fields and the question is you know some
level of knowledge of math is kind of
assumed by the time you get to the
college level but plenty is not and
that's sort of still centrally taught
the question is sort of how tall is the
Tower of kind of CX that you need before
you can just go use it in all these
different fields and you know there will
be experts who want to learn the full
elaborate Tower and that will be kind of
the the cscx whatever department but
there'll also be everybody else who just
needs to know a certain amount of that
to be able to go and do their art
history classes and so on
yes it's just a single class that
everybody is required to take I don't
know I don't know how big it is yet I
hope to kind of Define this curriculum
and I'll figure out whether it's um my
guess is that
I I don't know I don't really understand
universities and professoring that well
but my my rough guests would be a year
long a year of college class will be
enough to get to the point where most
people have a a reasonably broad
knowledge of you know what we sort of
literate in this kind of uh uh
computational way of thinking about
things yeah basic literacy